[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focus Channel and my name is Paul many
European languages share a lot of
features that seem to be the norm or the
default to speakers of those languages
but are actually quite unusual amongst
the thousands of languages of the world
and many of those features can't be
traced back to a common ancestor
language or proto-language rather it's
believed that there is a European sprock
bunte an area in which various languages
have influenced each other through
geographic proximity and contact this
fragment is sometimes referred to as the
European linguistic area and the set of
shared linguistic features is referred
to as standard average European most of
the languages of the standard average
European sprach boon or indo-european
languages but since a sprocket Bunte is
a geographic area of contact and
influence there are some non
indo-european languages that are also
marginal members of it as well including
Finnish and Hungarian most features of
standard average European are not from
proto-indo-european but hour later
innovations which then spread to other
European languages features that are
clearly part of standard average
European are found in a core of European
languages are not found in the Armenian
Iranian or Indic branches of
indo-european and are not found in the
majority of the world's languages sprach
boots affect different languages to
different degrees so there are some core
languages that exhibit most of the
features of standard average European
and there are others that exhibit fewer
this map shows nine characteristic
features of standard average European
and the number of features exhibited by
different languages at the core live
french and german which exhibit all nine
features Dutch Spanish Portuguese
Sardinian Italian and Albanian each
exhibit eight
English Romanian and Greek exhibit seven
the North Germanic languages as well as
Czech exhibit six Latvian Lithuanian
Russian Ukrainian polish Hungarian
Bulgarian Slovenian Serbian and Croatian
all exhibit five features languages with
fewer than five features are not really
considered part of standard average
European even though there may be some
per if
influence now let's take a look at those
nine features number one having both
definite and indefinite articles like
tha and ah in English only about one
third of the world's languages have
articles and the number of languages
with both definite and indefinite
articles is much smaller so it's
remarkable that in Europe so many
languages have both and that's evidence
of the standard average European schmuck
wound which languages have these
features all the romance languages all
Germanic languages except for Icelandic
which is the most geographically
peripheral Germanic language some Vulcan
languages including modern Greek and
maybe Albanian and Bulgarian which don't
have it Baltic and Slavic languages
possibly aside from Bulgarian here we
can see the German definite and
indefinite articles in all of their
inflected forms here we can see the
French definite and indefinite articles
and here we see the Hungarian definite
and indefinite articles number two
relative clauses with relative pronouns
these are relative clauses that come
after the noun with a relative pronoun
that changes depending on the function
of the head of the sentence for instance
in English the man who drives the car
versus the man whose car I drove in
German diamond a DeSoto Fiat
in German the relative pronoun comes
from a demonstrative pronoun but in most
cases the relative pronoun comes from an
interrogative pronoun in other words a
question word like in French
lunk economy negative and in modern
Greek the heat of the kimeta as you can
see from the map this feature is
widespread even outside of the core
standard average European languages
number three the have perfect like I
have finished the report in English this
is a periphrastic perfect tense using
the verb have plus a past participle
such a construction exists in all
Romance languages all Germanic languages
and some Vulcan languages including
modern Greek Albanian and Macedonian in
some of these languages it has a simple
past meaning and in other languages it
has a present perfect meaning here's an
example in German Ichabod in Buddhist
fatica state and in French
and in modern Greek a whole new Clio
sitting on áfourá number for a passive
formed with an intransitive linking verb
plus a past participle for example in
English the car was stolen this kind of
passive is used in all romance Germanic
and Slavic languages other languages of
the Balkans as well as to Celtic
languages Irish and Breton among others
in German does out of autogas stolen and
in French left with uit fully in Polish
Samaha Zastava Johnny and in Breton and
no tools with pelea hurt this type of
passive is rare outside of standard
average European but it should be noted
that it does appear in Iranian and Indic
languages so maybe it's an indo-european
feature rather than just a standard
average Europeans preponed feature
number 5 dative external possessors
these occur when the possessor and the
thing that's possessed appear in
separate noun phrases with the possessor
being in the dative case or an indirect
object for example in German
demotivation kindy ha
meaning the mother is washing the
child's hair but word-for-word it's the
mother washes the child dative case the
hair accusative case and an example in
Spanish no ladies to la cara meaning i
haven't seen his face but word for word
'it's know him indirect object have seen
the face number 6
negative pronouns with no verbal
negation for example in English nobody
came notice that the verb itself is not
negated this type of negation occurs in
all Germanic languages French Occitan
Ribeiro romance and Italo romance
languages as well as Albanian 1 Romance
language it doesn't appear in is
Romanian it's also absent from Slavic
Languages Uralic languages and others in
German neimand come and in French person
Avenue if we ignore no the main negation
word pas is not here to negate the verb
and these days people often skip the nut
anyway in Spanish and Italian this type
of negation is used but if the negative
pronoun is an object after the verb as
opposed to the subject then the verb is
negated for
example in Spanish no he visto another
seven comparisons of equality based on
an adverbial relative clause in English
we have comparisons like as tall as me
in German this would be Zulus V with me
being a relative adverb in other words
it's used to introduce a relative clause
like in this sentence he migui dude
angst meaning I like how you think in
English as is not used to introduce
relative clauses like that but it
derives from else wah or also which was
used as a relative pronoun in the past
and in modern Greek dos up si lo also
ago this feature appears in the romance
languages West Germanic languages Slavic
languages Hungarian Albanian and modern
Greek it's not found in North Germanic
languages finish the Celtic languages
and so on number eight non-pro drop
perhaps a more precise term for this is
strict subject agreement in most
languages verbs usually have a fixes
that indicate the subject and very
commonly the explicit subject pronoun
can be dropped for example in Arabic a
hit
which means I love you when spoken to a
female we know from the prefix aa that
this is first person singular so the
subject and the meaning I is often left
out but in certain European languages
including the course standard average
European languages of French and German
as well as Dutch English Welsh and
Icelandic the subject pronouns cannot be
dropped even though there are a fixes
that agree with the subject for example
in German ich liebe dich the subject
pronoun here is necessary and can't be
dropped this is one feature that only
applies to a limited number of standard
average European languages in Spanish
for example do TEM means I love you
Spanish is Pro drop the subject pronoun
here can be left out de amel but as a
side note in Spain it would be more
common to express love by saying you're
taquita
or dakedo meaning I want you but in
French it's shoot in French is non Pro
drop so the subject pronoun is required
even though syntactically it completely
lines up with the Spanish sentence if
the pronoun is included in the Spanish
sentence
number nine intensifier reflexive
distinction in English we used the word
self and its derivatives myself himself
and so on as an intensifier for example
the president himself gave a speech at
our school in the sentence the word
himself is an intensifier it emphasizes
that it's the President and not someone
else who gave a speech at the school but
in English and in many languages such
intensifiers are also used as reflexive
pronouns as well for example he loves
himself
but a typical feature of standard
average European languages is that
different words are used for the
intensifier and for the reflexive in
German the president zest meaning the
president himself and leap day meaning
he loves himself and in Polish some
president and cohosh shabbiha again we
have the intensifier and the reflexive
pronoun which are different in French
the prezi don't remember and is him this
is the direct translation of he loves
himself in French but this isn't really
a natural sentence for that meaning so
another example with a reflexive pronoun
is sooth would only mullah meaning he
sees himself in the mirror
obviously this differentiation does not
occur in English or in Dutch either but
it occurs in many standard average
European languages including those which
tend to have fewer Shiprock boned
features like the North Germanic
languages Latvian and Lithuanian and the
Slavic languages even Basque Basque is a
language isolate and not considered a
standard average European language
because it doesn't share enough of the
sprach bone features but it does share a
couple of them this is a good example of
how a sprach bone can have varying
degrees of impact on different languages
depending on geography and contact those
nine features are considered highly
likely to be part of a European Shiprock
boot there are numerous other features
which may be part of the sprat boot as
well but are less certain one such
feature is SVO word order
SVO for example in English I love
languages SVO and in German
SVO SVO is not limited to Europe but
within Europe it seems to correspond
well with the other core standard
average European features there's also
an absence of certain features that are
common in other regions of the world one
example is the absence of reduplicating
reduplicating is the repetition of a
word or part of a word usually to change
something about its meaning or function
for example in Indonesian there's the
word Ana which means child and anatomic
is the plural form meaning children
this type of reduplicating is almost
totally absent from standard average
European languages how did this Brock
bunte arise it's hard to know exactly
what historical events or conditions
contributed to the spread of standard
average European features but according
to Martin Haspel mass who's the source
of most of the information in this video
the most likely hypothesis is that it
happened during the migration period
between roughly 300 and 700 seee during
the transition from Late Antiquity to
the early Middle Ages during this time
the Western Roman Empire declined and
collapsed which triggered widespread
invasions into and within Europe
particularly into the territory of the
Empire the resulting migrations must
have brought many languages into contact
with each other of course this may be
responsible for some of the Schrock
Bunte features while other features may
have spread as a result of different
historical events one of the most
fascinating things about languages is
that they are a result of everything
that has happened to their speakers and
their ancestors up until this point the
question of the day is the rock Bunte in
your region or is there another sprach
book you've heard about what kind of
shared features are there let us know in
the comments down below if you enjoyed
this video then be sure to check out
Lange focus on the various social media
platforms like Facebook YouTube Twitter
and Instagram and as always I want to
say thank you to my patreon supporters
especially these wonderful patreon
supporters right here on the screen my
top tier patreon supporters many extra
special thanks to them and to everyone
thank you for watching and have a nice
day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]